tentant d'imaginer genre faire naître
des enfants sous l'eau mais ça c'était
déjà
bonjour à tous et bien ce mot l'épisode
2 tu imagines si j'aime bien la langue
de la chaîne syllabus moi c'est dingue
liliane je fais une chaîne de
numérisation scientifique et je suis
très très mauvaise un pitch mais grosso
modo ford tient de la vie quotidienne
avec des actes à rien moi ce que je
kiffe sur ta chaîne c'est que c'est très
pratique en bien du même genre c'est
hyper concret par exemple le fait de
savoir si on joue avec l'accélération
d'un ascenseur genre est-ce que tu pèses
plus lourd parce que tu es de les gens s
on sent une pression de l'encens constat
est ce qu'on pèse plus lourd abîme qu'on
va pour une balançoire et d'un ascenseur
la semaine sur tout ça très cool vous
verriez que pendant la cage de
l'ascenseur
vous n'avez évidemment pas changé de
masse mais vous ne posez pourtant pas le
même poids vous peser plus lourd quand
l'ascenseur accélère pour monter et
moins lourd quand il des salaires pour
ça que les gens nous on est plein de
réponses sur t'imagines si on respirait
dans l'eau et donc c'est ce qu'on va
lire la maintenant en somalie nom
générique
tu imagines si ya pas encore de
génériques mais ça arrive le monde se
diviserait en deux parties submarine ou
non ce qui engendrerait des écarts
sociaux bien plus important par rapport
aux possibilités des deux façades du mot
et possibilités de recherche au travail
s'il a retiré lesdits mutation d'état
devrait être vue sur tout notre monde
actuel reposant sur la technologie
l'électricité par extension je ne pense
pas que l'humanité sur un tel niveau
développement où cela accentuera encore
plus d éclairante de monde et surtout
ils seraient arrivés deux possibilités
soit le fait de vivre sous l'eau aurait
été abandonné par l'impossibilité d'y
parler et d'autres problèmes soulevés
précédemment soit dans le métabolisme ce
serait adapté nageoires pour simplifier
déplaçons marin et nouveaux modes de
communication peut-être par la pensée
enfin la guerre aurait été freiné par
cette vie sous-marine tout notre arsenal
actuel d'armes à feu ne serait jamais
développé mais d'autres types d'arbres
ont refait leur apparition
usant de propos était physique de l'eau
logiquement et la partie non immergé
aurait eu de nouveau le dessus et
énormément de choses déjà 6,1 sous l'eau
et sur l'eau un des deux qui sera mieux
qu'ils avaient un des endroits où les
gens préféreraient vivre et que l'autre
après t'es pas obligée de vivre non plus
les solos tu peux juste profiter
fait que tu es capable de graver mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut imaginer que si on
peut vivre sous l'eau il ya peut-être
des gens qui s'y installeraient s'il ya
des gens qui s'y installent
effectivement les gens soit tu préfères
vivent sous l'os tu perds pas eu sous
l'eau et donc le prix de l'immobilier
par exemple tu vois on peut imaginer qu
effectivement je reçois sous l'eau ça
coûterait beaucoup plus cher ou ou enfin
je vois ce qui veut dire sur les ingate
texte à mesa présuppose effectivement qu
on a déjà envie de vivre
après si on regarde notre monde à nous
avec le réchauffement climatique va y
avoir beaucoup de réfugiés climatiques
donc ce serait vachement pratique si on
arrivait à vivre sous l'eau c'est clair
parce qu'on aurait déjà les structures
qui vont se faire submerger petit à
petit je vais donc ouais ouais ça
pourrait être pratique d'un sens à ce
qu'après faudrait résoudre le problème
d'avoir le wifi sous l'eau oui c'est
gros gros problème
j'espère que ça implique aussi qu'on est
capable de couvrir les poux - elles
refermées parce que si tu prends un tuba
et tu m'as sous l'eau peut pas aller tu
parlais à un mètre de profondeur mais
pas beaucoup plus toujours il faut que
tu savais que la pression était pas
capable d'ouvrir suffisamment tes
poumons pour pour absorber est-ce qu'on
pourrait vivre sous l'eau mais à la
surface ou vraiment important d'heures
c'est encore une autre serait complète
question respirer sous l'eau n'implique
pas pour un vivre ensemble
exact c'est marrant parce que toi genre
quand on parle de la vie alors enfin
quand on parle de la respiration pour
nous c'est c'est comme si c'était le
suffisant à la vie on oublie que tu
adores la voix dans une pression qui
nous va on a une gravité qui nous va tu
vois on oublie tout un tas de trucs qui
sont pas ce que c'est on vit avec tout
le temps tu en voilà
là on fait le postulat que c'est ça
arrive pas maintenant mais ça arrive et
diamantin il a longtemps entouré
s'installer en milieu aquatique pour de
longues périodes ce qui pourrait aboutir
au fil des générations à une nouvelle
forme d'hommes qui auraient une et
killing equilibrio ception développé
pour se repérer dans un monde en trois
dimensions
contrairement à la terre ferme de grande
capacité à se repérer dans un monde bien
moins lumineux où le son se propage
différemment parce que tout toutes tes
notion d' équilibre le fait que tu
puisses te tenir sur un piège c'est
parce que tu as dans ton
à l'oreille interne tu es capable de
s'ajuster avec toutes et tous nous
accélérons notre interne on est capable
de s'ajuster à alain vironneau pop
attendait mais du coup c'était sous
l'eau t'as plus les mêmes besoins
d'équilibré et donc tu as développés où
tu va modifier un petit peu ton système
d' équilibre pour certainement arriver à
faire d'autre chose qu'être de tension
soi-même devriez vrillé sur les choses
resteraient sous l'eau peut-être mais
est ce que nous pourrions toujours
supporté la pression sous-marine
c'est son souhait teurs car si c'est le
cas les hommes devraient majoritairement
sur terre où la pression est la plus
portable
il y aurait la limite des villes sous
marine mais qui ne serait pas très
profond dans l'eau les hommes il
deviendrait plus musclée car sous fait
de nager en permanence grâce pour le
moment pas de nation sous marine
indépendance car les hommes de la
surface ont bien plus de pouvoir
développement des armes telles que j'ai
pu développer et c est alors peu de
chances que les hommes se mettent à
vivre sous l'eau mais il y aura sûrement
des loisirs possible sous l'eau et
peut-être beaucoup plus tard lorsque
l'on n'aura technologie nécessaire nous
pourrions éventuellement y vivre à
franchement impropre à prendre ni dit
les hommes deviendraient plus musclée
car ce fait de nager en permanence je
pense pas qu'on a joué très quoi je
pense qu'on va voter comme les scooters
des mers le scooter sous l'eau la sec
les eaux de turbines la théorie
s'accroche à un truc est ce que tu
développerait surtout d'autres muscles
parce que juste pour se tourner dans un
endroit plus besoin donc là forcément tu
développes d'autres muscles du dos des
bras que dans la vraie vie à part ouais
que tu vas pas beaucoup développée en
fait on verrait tout de suite les gens
si l'une sous le fouet sur prononcera
sur terre et demi avait clos son secours
de dos comme à cet outil la peau
toute fripée je vous la pauvre la
foule est pas fait pour ça en fait pour
ça surtout la halle au salé
je pensais encore pire comme une douce
mais en fait les villes sous marine
je pense qu'elle serait un peu comme
dans star wars sur toi le 1 la menace
fantôme et jar jar binks rapide sa
population on y vivre sous l'eau tu vois
je l'entendrai la ville sous-marine et
tu peux aller de ville en ville où te
promener machin à tous mais genre tu vas
pas vivre sous l'eau quoi ouais mais
c'est quand même pas pratique pour
habiter au québec toute l'année tu as le
monde extérieur où il fait moins verte
et pitt à l'intérieur où il fait plus et
quand tu sors c'est toujours une
aventure c'est faux que tu t'habilles il
faut que et donc j'imagine un petit peu
la ville la ville sous marine comme ça
vous faudrait que ben je te mettre un
maillot de bain parce que tu l'auras
rentrée mouillé après chez une personne
donc si on vivait sous l'eau en ayant
des des maisons qui sont sèches
oui il y aurait quand même une
problématique de hockey ça c'est en fait
ce serait comme le québec ya des gens
qui vivent là bas on sait pas trop
comment ils font mais la plupart des
gens vivraient pas là bas même si le
rapport aux catastrophes naturelles
liées à l'eau soit toujours existant
ouais effectivement oui tu auras des
catastrophes naturelles aussi sous l'eau
et tout mais moi je pense que soul les
gros danger ça serait plus les
prédateurs à l'accord les orques ils ont
clairement pas gentil or il ya pire que
les organes est aussi les au hawk-eye de
nouvelles maladies donc de nouveau
médecin noir ait donc nouvelle drogue
une nouvelle langue nouvelle insulte à
nouveau au milieu donc de nouvelles
façons de faire du sport une nouvelle
façon de déplacer une nouvelle façon de
faire du sexe nouvelles armes de
nouveaux moyens de communication toute
nouvelle façon cela avait-elle
automatique c'est sûr que si on pouvait
respirer sous l'eau
on aurait envie de faire quelque chose
c'est un nouveau terrain avec lequel
jouait là est tout le monde il ya des
startups qui vont se lancer dans des
trucs c'est certain et je pense que les
bâtiments sous marins ça boosterait
vraiment le développement de la
recherche en matériaux et il y aurait
peut-être des des innovations vraiment
intéressante qui ressortirait ça qui
nous aiderait nous sur terre à vivre
avec plus en plus en communion avec avec
l'eau donc je pense qu'effectivement si
on ouvrait ce nouveau marché là on
aurait plus de technologie puis
d'innovation et ça pourrait être aussi
donc je revenais sur quoi tient la
colonne vertébrale et nous comme un soir
elle se sentirait comment sur les sous
je pense ce serait comme l'espace
ou tu tues grandirait parce que tu en as
tu irais je pense parce que simplement
tata plus la gravité qui quittent
compris longue ans
tours est certainement à des nôtres
colonne vertébrale et les ans est un
petit peu je pense que tu es courbure
serait un petit peu moins prononcée
parce que si elle est en baisse c'est
parce qu'on les bipèdes et quand on a
besoin de marchés et que ça permet les
courbures permette de rééquilibrer les
forces un petit peu je pense qu'on
aurait un aplatissement de la colonne
vertébrale
sinon après les les poissons les tous
les animaux ont des tous les vertébrés
ont une colonne vertébrale donc elle
serait de toute façon il va mais je
pense avait beaucoup moins courbure via
cuda tu as un bon très bon c'est vrai
c'est que la prochaine fois
la question ce sera pour la prochaine
vidéo l'invité sera le capitaine de
nexus 6 et la question qu'on se posera
sera t'imagines si on pouvait se cloner
sous-entendu à partir de maintenant je
vous laisse y répondre en commentaire il
ya aussi une personne parmi vous dans
toutes les réponses qui a gagné 1 je
t'imagine ti donc je mets le nom de la
personne qui a gagné ici à saouler
apprendre des trucs cool d'une manière
cool
allez voir la chaîne syllabus je vous
remets le lien description trop bisous
ciao bye